عليه توكلت واليه انيب حسبي
الله احمده تعالى حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا حمدا يليق بجلال وجهه وكمال صفاته
وعظيم
سلطانه يا ربنا لا نحصي ثناء عليك انت كما
اثنيت على
نفسك واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي ويميت
وهو على كل شيء قدير واشهد ان سيدنا
وعظيمنا وقائدنا
وشفيعنا وحبيبنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف الغمه تركنا على المحجه
البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا هالك صلى الله
عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم
الدين اخص
بالذكر امراء المسلمين
بالحق ابي بكر وعمر وعثمان
وعلي وعن السبطين
الحسن والحسين وعن عمي النبي الكريمين
حمزه والعباس وعن ازواج النبي امهات
المؤمنين الطاهرات من الادناس
والارجاع بنات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
زينب ورقيه وام كلثوم ولا سما قره عين
الرسول فاطمه الزهراء البتول ورضي الله
سبحانه وتعالى عن السته البرره الذين هم
تمام العشره المبشره وعن بقيه الصحابه
والقرابه والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى
يوم الدين رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا
وعليهم
اجمعين فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي مذنب
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم
اوامره وكثره مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول
لعلكم ترحمون ايها المؤمنون واعلموا عباد
الله ان التقوى شعار المؤمنين ودثار
الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم
اجمعين فقد قال الله سبحانه وتعالى وهو
اصدق القائلين
اعوذ بالله السميع العليم من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها
الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون صدق الله
العظيم اما
بعد قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان عده الشهور عند الله 12 شهرا في
كتاب الله يوم خلق السماوات والارض منها
اربعه حرم ذلك الدين القيم فلا تظلموا
فيهن
انفسكم صدق الله
العظيم ايها
المسلمون نعيش
معكم هذه الايام
مباركه في شهر الله
المحرم احد الاشهر
الاربعه
وهي ذو القعده وذو الحجه
والمحرم ورجب
الاصن وقد كان العرب في
الجاهليه يعظمون هذه
الاشهر ولا يتقاتلون في
فيها حتى ان احدهم يرى قاتل ابيه ولا
يتعرض له حرمه وتعظيما لهذه
الاشهر ايها
المسلمون وهذا شهر
المحرم فيه من الفضائل
العظيمه كفضل الصيام
فيه فعن ابي هريره رضي الله
عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه
وسلم افضل الصيام بعد
رمضان شهر الله المحرم وافضل الصلاه بعد
الفريضه صلاه
الليل ومن خصائص هذا
الشهر ان فيه فضيله صيام
عاشوراء وهو العاشر من
محرم يوم انجى الله
تعالى سيدنا موسى عليه السلام
وقومه من
فرعون عن ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما قال لما قدم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم المدينه فوجد اليهود صياما يوم
عاشوراء
فقال لهم رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم ما هذا اليوم الذي
تصومونه
قالوا هذا يوم عظيم انجى الله فيه موسى
انجى الله فيه موسى وقومه واغرق فرعون
وقومه فصامه موسى عليه السلام شكرا فنحن
نصومه
فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله وسلم
فنحن احق واولى بموسى منكم فصامه رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وامر بصيامه متفق
عليه عن ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
واله وصحبه
وسلم لان بقي الى قابل لاصومن التاسع مع
العاشر يعني عاشوراء رواه الامام مسلم
رحمه
الله مخالفه لليهود فاجتهد اخي المسلم
اختي
المسلمه في صيام التاسع مع العاشر من هذا
الشهر
فهذه سنه نبينا صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم
ايها
المسلمون رب سائل
يسال متى ولماذا ابتدا المسلمون بالتقويم
الهجري اعلموا ان المسلمين بدات تتداخل
عليهم
السنين
والاحداث حتى كانت خلافه امير المؤمنين
عمر بن الخ طاب رضي الله تعالى عنه ففي
السنه الثالثه او الرابعه من خلافته رضي
الله عنه كتب اليه ابو موسى الاشعري رضي
الله
عنه انه ياتينا منك كتب ليس لها
تاريخ فجمع عمر رضي الله عنه الصحابه رضي
الله عنهم اجمعين فاستشارهم
من اين يبدا
التاريخ فقال
بعضهم
يبدا مبدا من مولد النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وهذا في
الصحيح وهذا دليل لمن ينكر الاحتفال بمولد
النبي بمولد النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام فقال
بعضهم فقال بعضهم
نبدا من مولد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقال بعضهم يبدا من
بعثته
وقيل يبدا من
هجرته وقيل من وفاته صلى الله عليه
وسلم ولكنه رضي الله عنه رجح ان يبدا من
الهجره لان الله فرق بها بين الحق
الباطل واعلموا عباد
الله يظن
البعض ان الهجره كانت في شهر
محرم وهذا من الخطا وانما هجره الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم كانت في ربيع الاول حيث
شهر مولده عليه الصلاه والسلام
فجعلوا مبتدا تاريخ السنين في الاسلام سنه
الهجره سنه الهجره وليس يوم الهجره لانها
هي التي كان فيها قيام كيان مستقل
للمسلمين وفيها تكوين اول بلد اسلامي
يحكمه
المسلمون ثم شاور عمر الص صحابه رضي الله
عنه رضي الله عنهم اجمعين من اي شهر
يبداون السنه فقال بعضهم من ربيع الاول
لانه الشهر الذي ولد فيه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم والشهر الذي قدم فيه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم مهاجرا الى المدينه وقال
بعضهم من رمضان
واتفق راي
عمر واتفق راي عمر
وعثمان وعلي رضي الله عنهم اجمعين على
ترجيح البداه
بالمحرم لانه شهر حرام ويلي ذي الحجه ويلي
الشهر الذي بايع فيه النبي النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم الانصار على الهجره فكان اولى
الشهور بالاولويه شهر
المحرم عباد الله ان علينا ان نشكر الله
تعالى على ما يسره لنا من هذا الحساب
البسيط الميسر في معرفه التاريخ اليومي
الذي دا من الهجره هجره النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم من مكه الى
المدينه وان علينا جميعا فرادا وامه مسلمه
ان نكون امه متميزه
باخلاقها ورايها
ومعاملاتها تميزا عن سائر الامم غير
المهتد بهدي الاسلام الطاهر لنكون امه عدل
وخير وامه صدق مع الله سبحانه وتعالى في
كل تصرفاتنا لي صل لنا صلاح احوالنا مع
انفسنا فنعيش الرضا والطمانينه والسكينه
وانشراح الصدر وقره العين بالايمان الصادق
ويحصل لنا صلاح احوالنا مع الناس
جميعا لان من اصلح ما لان من اصلح ما بينه
وبين الله اصلح الله ما بينه وبين الناس
ومن وكل على الله
كفاه فتعيش الامه حياه العزه والاباء
ويتحقق قول الله تعالى فيهم كنتم خير امه
اخرجت للناس تامرون بالمعروف وتنهون عن
المنكر وتؤمنون
بالله فان الخيريه والرفعه
والسؤدد توفيق من الله سبحانه وتعالى يحصل
بالايمان الصادق والامر بالمعروف والنهي
عن المنكر ولن يصلح اخر هذه الامه الا ما
اصلح
اولها ايها
المسلمون كما ان في هذا الشهر وفي يوم
عاشوراء
تحديدا حصلت فاجعه
للمسلمين يوم استشهاد سيد
الشهداء ريحانه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
واله وصحبه
وسلم الامام الحسين رضي الله عنه وارضاه
في واقعه الطف في كربلاء فارى ايها الاخوه
من الواجب على العلماء ان يبينوا للناس ما
حصل في تلك الواقعه الاليمه التي فجعت
الامه بها لذا ايها الاخوه والاخوات كونوا
معنا لنبين لكم بعض ما حصل في هذه الواقعه
الاليمه في الجمعه القادمه ان شاء الله
سبحانه وتعالى واستغفر الله العظيم لي
ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين
ادعوا الله وانتم موق نون بالاجابه